let's consider the motion of a symmetric
object that's rotating about a fixed
axis so we could take some object and we
can imagine this is sort of what
sometimes people refer to as a spinning
top and it's rotating about this
symmetry axis K and we know that the
angular velocity of the object we can
write as Omega ZK hat and the angular
momentum about this symmetry axis we
just showed that was equal to the moment
of inertia about this axis times the
angular velocity and in particular the
magnitude of the angular momentum I'll
just write that L about that axis is I
axis times the magnitude of the angular
velocity now we've seen separately that
the kinetic energy about this axis which
we'll call the rotational kinetic energy
was one-half times the moment of inertia
about that axis times the angular
velocity squared but here we see that
Omega squared is equal to L over I so if
we substitute that in we get L squared
about that axis over I axis squared and
so we have a nice expression for the
kinetic rotational kinetic energy is l
squared about that axis over to moment
of inertia about that axis and this we
can describe is the kinetic energy of a
symmetric body about a fixed axis it is
nice to notice the angular the linear
analogy to this when we wrote that the
momentum of an object was MV so the
magnitude of the momentum is just M
times V and when we write kinetic energy
translation as one-half MV squared we
can write that as a translational
kinetic energy as P squared
over 2m so once again we see this nice
analogy for rotational motion where we
describe it in terms of the angular
momentum and the moment of inertia and
the linear motion we describe in terms
of momentum and the mass